okay today i'm going to talk about
investigating
elasticity what we're going to look at
is a particular experiment
the results table and we're going to see
what the graph that accompanies it
looks like okay so first of all i'm just
going to introduce you to the experiment
here we have a spring and what we've
done
is this shows the same spring but with
different
amounts of force added to it each time
more and more of these hanging masses
have been added to the spring
and as you can see the more force
applied to the string
the further it extends so
the independent variable the things that
i'm changing the thing that i'm changing
on purpose
is the force applied to the spring and
the dependent variable the thing i'm
recording
is how far the spring extends so in
order to measure
the extension of the spring
i need to have a ruler which is attached
to the stand like this
so then i could measure the how far the
spring extends
as you can see this one here has got no
force applied to it at all so this is
the spring
before any force is applied there's no
force
and there's no extension now let's say
for sake of argument that each of these
hanging masses applies a force of an
extra 10 newtons
each time i add one
so the first one has zero newtons
applied to it
then 10 20 30 40. now i'm just going to
write this
in to the table here remember force is
measured in newtons
so i've got 0 10
20 30 and 40 newtons so that's my
independent variable what i need to do
each time
is i need to measure how far the spring
has extended
from its original shape so at this point
here we have an extension
of zero centimeters so this is what
we're measuring now the extension
nice and simply done using a ruler
so then the next one has extended a
certain amount
let's say that's extended one centimeter
this next one
has extended a total of two centimeters
this one has extended three centimeters
and this one has extended four
centimeters okay
so i'm just going to write these into my
table so
this one is zero then one two
three and four
so that basically is the experiment you
need to do
ideally you'd like to do at least six
different masses but i'm just going to
show
using four for now okay
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to show you
what the graph looks like that
accompanies this because we need to be
able to understand a couple of features
from this graph
now the first very unusual thing about
these elasticity graphs
is the fact that the independent
variable
actually goes on the y-axis normally the
independent variable
on pretty much every other graph we ever
do
the the independent variable goes on the
x-axis but there is an exception
when doing these extension graphs and
one of the reasons
behind that is the fact that
these graphs can be used to find the
spring constant
and it's slightly easier to find the
spring constant when
it's drawn this way round so that's
why the graph looks a little bit weird
because the independent variable
for a change is on the y axis okay
so this is extension
in centimeters here now
what we should find when we plot one of
these graphs
is obviously i'm not using a ruler or
graph paper here i'm just doing it free
hand
but hopefully we get the idea that we
should have
a nice linear relationship
to begin with so we should have a nice
straight line
here obviously i haven't been able to
draw it perfectly straight because i
haven't got a ruler
um just drawing freehand today but we
should have a nice straight line
now if we continued this experiment
so we kept on adding more and more force
we would find
two other things we would eventually get
to this particular point
which is called the limit
of proportionality
now what that means is is after this
point
we've added so many masses there's so
much force rather
that we no longer have a linear
relationship so it's no longer directly
proportional
that is called the limit of
proportionality now if we keep going a
little bit
further we get to another point
which is called the elastic
limit now what the elastic limit is
is when you've added so much force
that the spring can no longer return to
its original
shape it's said to be inelastically
distorted
so after that point the spring will not
return
to its original shape it is now
inelastically distorted
so that's an experiment to investigate
the force
force effect on extension this is what
the graph looks like remember it's a bit
unusual because the independent variable
the force
is on the y-axis remember we start off
with a nice
linear relationship so a nice straight
line then we get to the limit
proportionality
and the elastic limit if we kept on
adding more and more force to the
springs
thank you